the leader of the house rose on a point
of order to announce the government's
intention to bring forward a motion
today under Section 13 1b of the
European Union withdraw relax 2018
unfortunately the point of order did not
prove to be a prelude to an emergency
business statement on which colleagues
could question probe and scrutinize the
leader rather for approximately an hour
30 points of order were raised by no
fewer than 24 colleagues with me
expressing disquiet and consternation
that the government intended to require
the house to consider again on Monday
the same matter which it had decided 48
hours earlier on the immediately
preceding sitting day it was my
privilege to listen and respond to the
views of colleagues I then undertook to
reflect further on what members had said
and to give a ruling this afternoon
which I shall now do there are two
issues one of substance and the other of
circumstances to consider I shall
address each in turn
first I have to judge whether the motion
tabled under Section 13 1 B of the 2018
Act for debate today is the same in
substance as that which was decided on
Saturday page 397 of erskine May is
clear that such a motion may not be
brought forward again during that same
session it is equally clear that a do
dication of cases is a matter for the
chair I invoked erskine May and ruled on
this issue as recently as March
the 18th this year Saturday's motion
sought approval for the withdrawal
agreement the political declaration on
the future relationship between the EU
and the UK and the declaration
concerning the operation of the
Democratic consent in Northern Ireland
provision
today's motion seeks approval for the
withdrawal agreement the political
declaration on the future relationship
between the EU and the UK and the
declaration concerning the operation of
the Democratic consent in Northern
Ireland provision it is clear that the
motions are in substance the same
however this matter was decided
fewer than 49 hours ago after more than
three hours of debate the House voted by
322 to 306 for sir Oliver let wins
amendment which stated that and I quote
this house has considered the matter but
with holds approval unless and until
implementing legislation is passed
unquote the second matter for me to
consider was whether there had been any
change of circumstances that would
justify asking the house to reconsider
on Monday what it had decided on
Saturday on the face of it unless an
event or development external to the
house had interceded it is hard to see a
significant change of circumstances that
would warrant a reconsideration on the
next sitting day in this case a
reconsideration pre announced by the
leader of the house just under 21
minutes after the result of the division
was announced
however the government might argue
though to date it hasn't put forward any
argument or explanation at all that the
change of circumstances is the Prime
Minister's application on Saturday night
for an extension of article 50 this is
not persuasive the application is this
is not persuasive the application is
part of a process rather than a
significant event in itself
in summary today's motion is
extraordinarily grateful to the
Honorable Genevieve bears directly with
fortitude I shall complete my statement
in summary today's nation is in
substance the same as Saturday's motion
and the house has decided the matter
today's circumstances are in substance
the same as Saturday's circumstances my
ruling is therefore that the motion will
not be debated today as it would be
repetitive and disorderly to do so
for the benefits of colleagues not
closely familiar with the so-called same
question convention which is very strong
and dates back to 1604 I will summarize
the rationale for it in a sentence it is
a necessary rule to ensure the sensible
use of the houses time and proper
respect for the decisions that it takes
if it is not legitimate for the motion
to be taken today
what is it legitimate for the government
to do the answer is that as the Prime
Minister himself signaled in his point
of order
on Saturday at column six five three and
in his letter to members that evening
the government can introduce its EU
withdrawal and implementation bill
indeed it has done just that
presenting the bill for its first
reading today I have no doubt that the
leader will offer further details of the
intended timetable for the bill when he
makes a business statement later today
meanwhile I hope that this ruling and
explanation are helpful to the house
[Laughter]
yes point of order mr. Peter Berg Thank
You mr. speaker I entirely follow the
logic of your argument but what weight
did you give to the point that when we
were debating on Saturday nobody knew
whether the Prime Minister was going to
send a letter or not whilst you are
quite correct sir to say that the motion
is the same an event outside has
dramatically changed it and given that
the motion on Saturday is very clear
that final approval can't be done until
the deal has gone through in legislation
well did not be as you've always said to
let the house decide on this matter
notwithstanding the fact that the
previous motion is clear what actually
is going to happen it would give the
country the opportunity to know whether
this house of crews or disapproval of
the Prime Minister still be grateful to
the honourable gentleman for his point
of order
my response is as follows I did not
consider in reaching a judgment on this
matter whether a letter would be sent
the letter was sent on Saturday evening
more widely however the question of
whether it would be a material
consideration for the chair whether a
minister of the crown would obey the law
the honest answer to the honourable
gentleman is that that consideration had
not entered my mind as pertinent to my
reflection on the matter I note the
wider point that the Honorable gentleman
makes and I respect the fact that it is
a point of view and I intend no
discourtesy to the Honorable gentleman
when I say that I think I have made the
argument for and explained the rationale
behind the judgment that I have made I'm
not seeking to rubbish
honorable gentlemen I'm simply making no
I'm not seeking to rubbish the honorable
gentleman I'm simply making the point
that having reflected on all of the
considerations and the interests of the
house I have reached the conclusion I
have reached and it is important that
colleagues here all parts of it and the
honourable gentleman didn't like part of
it as he's politely explained in his
point of order but he will also have
heard me say what is open to the
government to do and the government can
introduce its bill and the government
can propose a program motion for it and
the government can proceed with the
support of the house between now and the
end of the month as collectively
Parliament prescribes and that seems to
me to be entirely proper I will come to
other colleagues yes I'll come to other
gub particularly the illustrious chair
of the European scrutiny committee but
first of all a point of order mr. Kevin
Brennan Thank You mr. speaker as you'll
recall on Sat